I know your names but not why you're  here  renowned master mentor  it's your LD Torre de la la la it is a  good life really brother they never  change  your father was an assassin impressing  all that remains is the deal this life  it chose me  you flew and so you flew you are the  leader now unite the assassin Victoria  and take back Roma if I want I  tend to write a book about you one day  you do Machiavelli make it short  welcome to Constantine yashio  fight with me  and show him what it means for us dance  happy  requiescat in pond sale Assassin's Creed  the SEO collection available November  15th pre-order now purchase Assassin's  Creed the NCO collection and get a free  assassins creed movie ticket about doing  $8 total value offer valid at select  retailers while supplies last